j'accueille avec bachir
je crois qu'on va faire une interview
acteur studio
[Musique]
alors est ce que tu pourrais nous jouer
la peur
la savoie y était la colère
un homme qui dit je t'aime avec les yeux
avec la dj
est ce que tu veux jouer l'homme qui
veut faire comprendre à une femme qui la
veulent là tout de suite maintenant
varié on a attaché son nom
fait mouche et nous fait nous le truc ça
me fait le sérieusement
j'aime pas du tout et les comédiennes
comme toi enfin que je la mange
maintenant non pas que tu m'as mange que
tu la regardes le jeu aussi
tout le monde en a parlé à retrouver
greg basso à paris et mort à l'hôpital
robert debré pour rejoindre
l'association dont je suis le parrain
depuis plusieurs années il est en effet
engagé auprès de l'association navy et
surtout envers ses fondateurs la famille
carpentier oui et non merci d'être là
de rien mais va le vieux au programme
aujourd'hui une livraison d'ordinateurs
portables grâce à greg l'association a
déjà pu offrir à l'hôpital délit ou
encore des télévisions avec lecteur dvd
dont emma tortes enfants au moins tu
peux leur maître les jeux les machins
donc voilà berlin 19 ordinateur axerons
père ancien mais qui sont équipées de
plus de 400 jeux à l'intérieur pour les
gamins aient
à leur disposition des jeux éducatifs
des jeux ludiques et
grand effort bah vous remercier
l'association navy surtout puisque avoir
particulier martial eu aussi la passe à
son tour en fait sans répétition ces
moments privilégiés sont aussi
l'occasion de passer du temps avec
raphaël dont greg est devenue très
proche
c'est petit frère c'est ici je suis
comme le parrain ces turbines j'espère
garçon que je me suis dit si bien qu'il
est courageux ce bonhomme il est
beaucoup plus courageux que moins que
tous les gens que je connais
pensez vous
obama allait nicolas c'est déjà l'heure
de se quitter greg retourne à sa vie
professionnelle
direction rue serre
et c'est son ami et associé qui
l'accueille pour une après midi bien
rempli
non là j'arrive de paris et me voilà à
bruxelles me voilà bruxelles parce que
parce qu'on organise une grosse grosse
soirée ce soir à bruxelles avec davies
avec un grand dj divisa et et moi-même
aux platines aussi
là on va suivre moi je vais le faire
discrètement parce que je veux pas trop
me faire voir pendant la parade mais on
va suivre l'équipe qui qui fait la
parade et qui va distribuer un peu des
flyers pour la promo
discrètement et enfin pas facile dans un
énorme 4 4 qui use in
[Musique]
car ce mec d'arc ardèche
et avant la soirée y s'accordent une
pause détente
enfin c'est sans compter sur les galères
d'organisateurs
konan didier qui a raté son avion
caresser scénario est d'une bêtise et
une petite galère et
il a raté son avion donc on essaye de
résoudre le problème et soin de leur
peau d'un deuxième billet sur de
remplacer par quelqu'un d'autre et voilà
ça fait neuf ans qu'on n'ait pas tourné
on jouera tous les moyens toute manière
on se voit tous les mois je connais très
bien sa femme ses enfants tout ça je
vais souvent 16h30 lanvaux club où on
organise la soirée soir on a un très bel
endroit tu vas très très violent droite
et j'avais lettres ligne là bas c'est
super beau
deuxième galère avec le gps cette fois
pas facile de tout gérer
légèrement à droite non mais c'est une
blague
non à droite c'est la bad ne faut pas
aller là-bas c'est pas par là bas ça
parlera par la passe et l'économie
[Applaudissements]
enfin arrivé greg ne perd pas de temps
et alors que la soirée approche la
pression commence un peu à monter pour
le dj son impatience aussi j'aime bien
que quand j'arrive dans la soirée
particulièrement quand c'est la soirée
que tout bon matin soit déjà prêt que
j'ai plus qu'à le brancher à m'éclater
un petit peu à quoi et que tout marche
correctement les essais sont les machins
parce que quand le son est pas bon c'est
pas terrible c'est pas terrible très
exigeant quand il s'agit de musique le
caractère du sudiste se fit sentir en
cas de problème technique et un nul
c'est toi qui es tu as passé juste pour
voir si ça marche et
ça m'a inquiété là j'ai eu peur
[Musique]
quatre coeurs
finalement tout est prêt à y file à son
dernier rendez vous la visite d'un club
qu'il va reprendre avec son ami
e
emballé par le lieu les deux associés
imagine déjà la transformation a battu
voit les gens là puissent apprécier tout
ça
non c'est bien c'est bien
libérer club grec deviendra-t-il le
nouveau roi de la nuit bruxelloise
à suivre
[Musique]
et maintenant la lumière se rallume sur
grégory basso gégory bonsoir bienvenue
sur le plateau de tout le monde a parlé
vous êtes né le 20 avril 1974 à manosque
en haute-provence père chef de chantier
soit lignes à haute tension ce qui fait
que voyager dans toute la france vos
parents vivent en caravane et c'est le
dépaysement toute l'année quoi quand
qu'un petit tout petit tu te rends pas
compte en fait mais c'est quand tu dis
que tu te rends compte que tu as une vie
un peu particulière en fait jusqu'à mes
huit ans j'avais pas vraiment d'endroit
c'était toujours d'un endroit à l'autre
mais ça pouvait être deux mois la trois
mois la 8 - là donc t'as pas vraiment le
temps de faire date h avec des gens et
de te faire de vrais amis non plus quand
vous avez huit ans en est votre petite
soeur johanna et là vos parents décident
de se poser à valréas donc temps
vaucluse le monde d'où mon père venait
en fait trop mais grands parents avaient
avec maison alors à l'école vous
préférez le foot et le judo plus tard la
muscu aux études et à 16 ans vos
résultats scolaires fléchissent
sérieusement vous aurez du mal à avoir
le bac ouais alors que j'étais j'avais
plutôt des grosses capacités j'avais des
supers résultats l'école toujours partir
du moment où je suis parti en internat
je suis parti c'est parti en live et
commence à repartir un peu en live
alors l'été pour gagner un peu de sous
fait des petits boulots comme ça que
vous apprendrez la maçonnerie voilà mes
deux aventure vous tente
c'est en terminale que vous quittez le
droit chemin pour la première fois avec
une bande de potes de votre classe vous
piquez les ordis vous la jouer un peu
l'ancien gangster patronnant petit con
plutôt un le problème si vous faites
filmé dans la station-service en train
de pays en afrique le chéquier volé en
même temps que les ordinateurs
reprenez 12 mois avec sursis
là vous devenez étudiant à montpellier
juste après et pendant trois ans avec
votre pote karim et toute une bande de
rêveurs vous allez vous défendre c'est à
l'acide et aux ecsta vous finirez quand
même par prendre 25 experts par week-end
quand même c'est arrivé une paire de
fois où vraiment on sait me met dans des
états dans d état pitoyable on se
rendait pas compte en fait on était dans
notre délire on est et on était dans
l'oreille ce parti honni mist musique et
c'était presque normal pour nous d'en
prendre alors que ça n'était pas du tout
mon était dans un petit monde parallèle
je dirais un instant une petite bulle en
fait évidemment vos études passent vite
au second plan la fac devient minuscules
détails dans votre vie ouais c'est clair
la fac c'était plutôt le rendez-vous des
copains et des copines qu'autre chose à
la main et le jour où fait un mauvais
trip vous décidé de diminuer la cam mais
vous devenez dealer en fait j'ai
commencé petit à petit à faire des
règles parti a défoncé un petit peu le
week end et puis au bout d'un moment
comme j'avais pas spécialement d'argent
pour t'acheter ta consommation de thiam
acheté une dizaine et en revendre et 8
ans gardé de pour toi et c'est venu
comme ça c'est devenu un engrenage en
fait jusqu'au jour où je rencontre le
fameux g voilà la fameuse personnes qui
me propose un deal un peu plus le plus
gros alors là c'est la grande vie à vous
prenez un appartement de 95 mètres
carrés à montpellier vous dîner au
restaurant vous offrez des bouteilles à
tout le monde dans les boîtes un ouais
c'était l'époque
[Musique]
de débilité je dirais aujourd'hui
qu'elle partait en vacances à ibiza st
barth puis on invite tout le monde en
fait j'ai invité un peu tout le monde
évidemment au pays des billets ont payé
tout à tout le monde parce que c'étaient
nos amis c'est un peu comme des frères
on est et on faisait confiance à tout le
monde c'était vraiment une bulle on
était dans un monde à part on était
ensemble des pas compte de la réalité en
fait on était complètement sorti de la
réalité de la vie réelle alors c'est à
cette époque que vous essayez devenir
mannequin à paris en fait vous
redescendez chaque week-end à
montpellier toujours pour faire des
affaires la fête et pour continuer
et en 1997 tout va basculer en plein
milieu de l'été 97 je suis je suis
prévenue par un ami qui habitait dans le
sud de la france dans le village de mes
parents que comme des mecs que je
fournisse et moi une époque ouais
c'était fait attraper et m'avait balance
est donc là branle bas de combat
j'essaye de prévenir tout le monde les
histoires que tout le monde essaie de
s'organiser soit qu'on se casse qu'on
reste en cavale ce que moi je fais
d'ailleurs soin qu'on soit content
s'organisent pour pour limiter la casse
et ça devient vite compliqué parce que
je vois que les gens ne prennent pas au
sérieux et puis se font arrêter les uns
après les autres et moi hélas hélas non
là vous vous êtes en cavale d'ibiza je
vais à barcelone et là j'essaie de
trouver les papiers pour partir pour
partir en uruguay je voulais partir je
me suis dit c'est bon je vais tout mais
ouais et avant de partir ou les revoir
vos parents et ce sont eux qui
parviendront à vous convaincre de vous
rendre ouais et c'est quand je les ai
vus à barcelone que j'ai vu ma mère
pleurait que j'ai vu mon père pleurer
également et mon père c'est un vrai
bonhomme ouais je n'avais jamais vu
pleurer que ça m'a touché et ça m'a
touchée ça m'a fait beaucoup de mal j'ai
ressenti la tristesse qu'ils avaient en
eux et j'ai dit je peux pas leur faire
ça j'aurais dit a fait le compte tu vas
payer tu vas subis tu vas rentrer comme
un grand là vous vous retrouvez en
prison à avignon et à tarascon après le
procès vous prenez cinq ans ferme mais
vous serez les enfants libérés au bout
de deux ans et demi quand même pour
bonne conduite en liberté conditionnelle
bonne conduite mais à partir du moment
où j'ai commencé à avoir mes premières
perm sortait de trois fois de la prison
par semaine pour donner des cours du
rugby au aux gamins du club de tarascon
donc ils voyaient que j'étais quelqu'un
qui on pouvait avoir confiance j'avais
une promesse de boulot à l'extérieur
j'avais ma famille voyez que je t'ai pas
non plus envoyé puis un fou quoi j'étais
pas un mec violent ni quoi que ce soit
là vous devenez l'assistant d'un pierce
heures dans le marais
j'ai tout fait je deviens je bosse dans
un magasin de piercing je vends des
perséides et à tous vous êtes vendeur de
fringues dans le sentier haute dans des
salons et strip teaseur déception
sentimentale un pote à moi qui me kim
propose un plan pour être chippendales
pour faire un casting de chippendales
aux folies bergère mais
hélas je me dis bon
que peu plus dit quand même je suis pas
avancé du touch et je suis très pato et
je me dis bon je vais y aller en fait il
fait le casting ça se passe bien
j'enchaîne je commence le jour même et
pendant cinq six mois on est resté aux
folies bergère à se mettre en string
tous les soirs devant 1000 à 1500 nana
tous les soirs à thury ça fait bizarre
et après vous voyagez vous allez en
turquie en juin
en fait j'ai fait plein voyage grâce au
street grâce aux gogos en particulier
parce que j'aimais pas trop le strip je
me sentais pas vraiment à l'aise j'étais
un peu timide malgré tout mais ça m'a
permis de beaucoup voyager
alors à l'époque votre boulimie sexuelle
remplace l'addiction à la drogue mais
disons qu'à une époque j'ai plus de j'ai
plus de sexe du tout pendant longtemps
et je crois que c'est ce que je me suis
rattrapé par la suite en fait j'ai fait
une petite boulimie sexuelle ensuite
vous zone et argent à eurodisney voilà
vous passer quand même six mois en pagne
dans la jungle quoi ouais c'est
exactement ça pour moi bosser euro
disney ça a été une des unes des
meilleures expériences de boulot que
j'ai eues dans le milieu artistique je
pense y avait une super ambiance on
était une soixantaine sur scène y avait
vraiment un truc avait une magie là bas
on parle de 10 n'est tout ça mais nous
moi et moi je parle de tout ce qui se
passe dans les backstage et tarzan ce
n'était pas juste faire la parade et
faire le pitre dans la parade bien que
ça se soit dur aussi c'était vraiment
des numéros de cirque des sangles des
trucs vraiment physique que j'avais
jamais fait de ma vie pour lesquelles
j'ai été formé pendant un mois je peux
vous dire que j'ai galéré j'ai encore
les cicatrices au journal
après vous faites des films érotiques
j'ai fait quelques clips de chardin moi
j'avais le bras on peut dire des films
érotiques mais c'était pas vraiment des
lubies horno quoi c'est pas du porno il
n'y avait pas de dialogue en voyait pas
mon sexe mais je n'en voyais pas ce qui
se passait après non plus mais
finalement jamais personne non personne
dit aux folies bergères n'y avait pas de
folies bergères c'est arrivé une fois
parra par inadvertance par accident
alors c'est là que tf1 vous choisi pour
être greg le millionnaire dans une
émission de télé réalité or le pitch
c'est un millionnaire qui cherche la
femme de sa vie vous avez une maison à
albi ça et vous accueillez toutes ces
demoiselles qui et c'est évidemment de
se brancher avec vous alors vous virer
marjolaine
j'adore
pourquoi vous n'avez pas pris parce
qu'elle est et ce qu'elle est et malines
et qu'elle savait qu'il fallait que ça
sorte du jeu parce que parce que je
savais très bien quelle sawicki que
j'étais un imposteur et que je jouais la
comédie parce qu'on s'était déjà croisé
avant l'époque et puis j'avais fait ce
que j'avais à faire un chèque au nom et
vous choisissez marica avant de lui
avouer évidemment vous n'êtes pas
millionnaire avant de lui avouer mais
elle s'en douter aussi un petit peu
quand même je pense qu'elle va faire mal
qui s'invitait dans la maison mais elle
tombera amoureuse de vous après
l'émission l'un comme l'autre on est
tombé amoureux après l'émission il
restait presque un an et demi ans
alors au moment de l'émission évidemment
on parle que de vous
quelles ont été les réactions de vos
parents
devant ça mes parents et mes parents
c'est les gens très très terre à terre
je dirais mai et qui ont beaucoup de
recul vis-à-vis de tous a déjà la base
même si c'était à nouveau la téléralité
ma mère elle disait oui mais tu enflamme
pas et je ne trouvais toujours été du
genre à me dire aussi tu t'enflammes on
va prendre un coup de pied au cul plutôt
qu'autre chose seul truc qui les a
acquis les a on va dire soul et c'est
que j'ai eu l'idée ils ont eu des
centaines d'appels anonymes et pendant
pendant deux ans avec les médias comment
ça s'est passé les médias ça a été bien
par moments c'était plus dur par moment
il n'y a jamais eu de trucs trop trop
trop méchant je pense dans les médias il
ya eu des trucs un peu déformé mais je
pense pas qu'on met tant de massacres et
que ça non plus les publics les voici
régulièrement j'ai encore des articles
de temps en temps mais ça me casse pas
ça peut arriver qu'un petit nice mais je
pense que je pense que j'ai quand même
une image assez sympathique pour le port
pour la plupart des gens non j'espère en
tout cas vous avez gagné de l'argent
j'ai gagné de l'argent j'en ai dépensé
beaucoup j'en ai regagné après généreux
dépensé générale gagne sadc ma vie en
fait depuis depuis neuf ans que j'ai
fait ce que j'ai fait greg le
millionnaire a été assez comme ça mais à
chaque fois que j'ai eu un petit creux
j'ai ma bonne étoile qui revenue comme
c'est le cas en ce moment et il se passe
des choses formidables donc c'est cool
et l'amour après marie cas j'ai
rencontré catherine à une le tchèque
avec qui je suis resté pendant presque
presque qu'à 33 ans et demi
le regret de ma vie je pourrais dire
aujourd'hui je pense je pense que
j'aurais dû l'épousé de faire un bébé
ouais je suis toujours pas mariée j'ai
pas d'enfants mais ça me pèse un petit
quand même ça me fait un petit peu quel
était le meilleur moment de cette époque
greg le millionnaire je crois que c'est
juste après l'émission qu'un petit monde
quand tf1 nous a obligés à partir en
vacances forcées à los angeles et miami
pendant et au mexique pendant un mois et
demi et là j'étais au paradis j'avais
tout ce que je voulais sur royal s'était
offert beaucoup s'étaient offert par tf1
et ça c'est tellement rare ça me fait du
bien ça fait du bien et le pire moment
je sais pas si j'ai vraiment eu des
sales moments coire et gpu trop de
salons mais j'ai vraiment eu plein de
bonnes expériences j'ai beaucoup voyagé
j'ai ma vie a quand même pas mal changé
grâce à ça alors ensuite fait un peu de
théâtre un peu de télé un peu de musique
on vous retrouve dans la ferme
célébrités 3 c'est ça le pire moment
est ce que j'allais le pire moment de
télé ou de quoi que ce soit de ma vie
que j'ai que j'ai eu pendant un bref
instant on va dire ces trois mois c'est
cette émission cette émission en
particulier il ya des moments où j'étais
là bas je me suis dit ben je suis mis en
prison j'étais bien quand j'étais en
prison aujourd'hui vous êtes nostalgique
de l'époque greg le millionnaire non du
tout non non non du tout au contraire
aujourd'hui on me reconnaît toujours
beaucoup dans la rue je suis encore pas
mal sollicité mais je suis quand même
bien plus tranquille t'as pas les
paparazzis qui tu cours après t'as rien
du tout je suis royal veut dire v de la
rancune contre des gens j'ai pu en avoir
une époque mais franck plus je vieillis
plus j'ai tendance à pardonner et même à
oublier en fait alors c'était à refaire
votre vie y est ce que vous ne referiez
pas pareil
les bêtises que j'ai fait quand j'étais
à la fac la raison et partir en live
texte à quoi non partir en couille tout
simplement alors que je venais du jeu
vient quand même d'une bonne famille
j'ai une bonne éducation j'ai des femmes
mais j'ai des parents bien et qui m'ont
donné une bonne éducation et je sais pas
pourquoi je suis parti en vrille comme
ça pourquoi j'ai arrêté le judo alors
que j'avais des supercapacités aussi mon
grand regret en fait c'est ça je crois
que si j'avais jamais arrêter le judo je
devais rentrer un sport études j'avais
un super niveau et ce à partir de là que
c'est parti en vrille en fait
bizarrement à mes 16 ans il est plus le
judo comme guide comme moi c'était
j'étais complète complete compet egée
après je suis parti en arrive qu'elle
voulait qu'on marque sur votre ton quand
vous serez mort j'aurais pas de tombe je
me ferais incinérés ouais je suis comme
les bouddhistes et comme les indiens
j'aime bien j'aime un j'aime à penser
que notre âme passé levés vers le ciel
ou qu'ils aient une autre ville les fans
ou est ce qu'ils vont aller apporter des
fleurs alors qu'il fait on vit pas pour
les fans et les fans ne vivent pas pour
nous non plus bon on sait pour qui je
serai dans quelques années très bien
merci c'est très
bon aussi merci ça me fait plaisir et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de 1h10
tube abonnez vous il m'était impossible
eux